It's great to welcome to the program today.
Justin Elliott, who's been a reporter with
Propublica since 2012 where he's covered money
in politics, the American Red Cross and the
Trump administration.
Recently he's been covering the taxpayer first
act, which we've also been talking about.
Justin, great to have you on.
Hey, good to be here.
So for people who don't know, what is the
taxpayer first act, what, what does it do?
Sure.
So it's actually kind of like an omnibus bill
that, uh, makes a bunch of changes to the
IRS.
But the thing that we've been focused on is
it in its old version, it would have put into
law a, a deal between the IRS and the tax
filing industry.
Uh, basically turbo tax, uh, that would have,
among other things restricted the IRS from
creating its own sort of government tax filing
system.
Right?
That's exactly right.
And we, uh, so, uh, Richard Neal, who's the
congressman here in Massachusetts has been
involved with this and sort of sadly, I mean,
I like the guy personally and he was like
the first when I started doing this show,
the first sort of real elected official that
I ever met.
Uh, but I'm not particularly thrilled with
his role in this and it's not necessarily
a unique role.
I mean, this is actually relatively uncontroversial
within some sort of establishment circles
in the House and Senate that they th th th
there seems to be a sort of a, you scratch
our back, we'll scratch yours sort of crony
capitalist.
I mean, it's like the worst of the worst in
an area that a lot of people don't even know,
uh, is taking place in a sense.
Yeah, I mean, so it gets into this whole,
the whole area of tax filing and sort of,
you know, the annual ritual that we all go
through doing our taxes.
Um, it turns out that in a lot of other countries,
uh, no one really has to spend hours filling
out forms and doing their taxes.
And the fundamental reason for that is that
the tax agency often already has your data.
So if you're, if you're getting paid every
couple of weeks and taxes are being automatically
taken out of your paycheck, right?
Then the IRS, the IRS already has all those
numbers.
And so in many other countries, they have
what's sometimes called return free tax filing,
which is basically, uh, the IRS takes all
the numbers that already have prepopulates
your return.
Um, and then you sort of just look at it and
click okay if it's all good.
And so the question becomes, well, why don't
we have that here?
And the answer, or at least part of the answer
is that turbo tax, uh, the company that makes
it in to it, um, and the rest of the industry
have been lobbying against, uh, that kind
of system for at least 20 years at this point.
Yeah.
And so, so the, the way this works is pretty
simple, which is if you make money off of
a process that is perceived as too complicated
to do or actually is too complicated to do
without these pieces of software, you're far
more likely to buy one of these pieces of
software and pay, pay the filing fees.
Now, what a lot of people don't know, and
correct me if I'm wrong, I'm going off the
top of my head.
If you make under some certain amount of money
a year, it might be in the 60 thousands federal
filing at ready is free.
And those companies like TurboTax provide
that free federal filing, but they just don't
make it too easy to figure that out for yourself.
[inaudible] you're, you're exactly right.
So basically what what has happened is a turbo
tax and the rest of the industry have made
this deal with the IRS.
It's called free file.
Um, and the deal says, uh, two things.
First it says that the IRS can't create its
own system so the government can offer you
essentially its own turbo tax or they can't,
uh, or you know, create something like that.
And in exchange, the industry is supposed
to provide free filing.
Two people this year was making under $66,000,
which turns out to be actually the majority
of the country.
Yeah.
And then what you experience and when you
actually go to choose the version of turbo
tax or whatever that you're going to use,
it doesn't, uh, it's not made evident that
there is such an option.
And instead you're immediately sort of upsold
with if you want to maximize your deductions,
take advantage of deduction finder.
If you have any schedule C income or did any
sort of work on the side, you should get the
small, uh, small and home business edition
or something along those lines.
Now, what's important to understand is that
that does not account for the state.
Where, correct me if I'm wrong, those costs
are actually regulated at the state level
and are not free on the basis of income.
Um, it's so it's a whole sort of complicated
patchwork.
And so the at, at the heart of it is, as I
mentioned, there's this program called free
file that actually literally most Americans,
70% should be able to use, uh, to file at
least federally for free.
Um, but what, what TurboTax intuit, the company
that makes TurboTax has done is create a separate
product that very confusingly is called just
free.
So free file and free are different things.
Um, and uh, almost no one actually finds the
sort of truly free a free file version because
intuit advertises this other version.
And if you end up in this quote unquote free
edition, in fact, many people will end up
having to pay a hundred, 200 bucks.
Uh, even though if they had just gone to a
different website, it would have actually
truly been free.
And this is essentially a significant part
of the company's business model at this point.
What's the argument that the government makes
for new capping itself on this?
In other words, we can kind of try to infer
what's going on behind the scenes, but what
is this sort of public facing explanation
that the government says we believe in restricting
ourselves in this way?
You know, that's a really good question.
I've actually never heard anyone at the IRS
could dress that aspect of it.
I would be very interested to, to hear their
answer.
And we've asked them about this.
Um, what they will say more generally is that
they support this program because it's a public
private partnership where the government,
instead of having to spend money on creating
its own system and employing people, uh, will
sort of lean on this already existing private
industry that's, that's offering this product,
uh, for free, which sounds good.
[inaudible] might be a good thing, uh, if
people were actually using it.
But in fact something like two or maybe 3%
of Americans who are eligible for this free
fall program actually use it.
So virtually no one who's eligible actually
uses it.
Um, and we've never really been able to get
any one of the government to comment on, on,
you know, why those numbers are so low and
sort of what their thinking is in the program.
This seems to me like one of those things
that has really negatively affected by, uh,
the way that our election system works and
the way that appropriating money works.
Because if you want to, it would take longer.
Certainly.
Would it be my guests then like a term in
the house to make this a reality?
If the government did want to develop its
own system and software, uh, it might even
take longer than a presidential term.
And so in the short term, if you want to push
this forward, you would, all of these elected
officials who are not actually going to be
around in all likelihood or might not be around
when it actually becomes real, but they have
to take the sort of political hit of saying
they want to spend the money and appropriating
the money and the, you know, uh, political
football of debt and deficit.
Why bother, right.
They can just accept contributions from these
industries and keep doing what they're doing.
Yeah, I mean, so there's a, there's a couple
of things going on.
So first of all, as you know, so I mean in
to it and h and r block, the rest of this
industry are, uh, giving a lot of money to,
um, members of Congress of both parties.
I, including Richard Neal.
Um, they're in Massachusetts who of course
is the chairman of the tax writing committee
ways and means committee in the house.
Um, they're also spending millions of dollars
lobbying.
It's very much a sort of bipartisan thing.
Um, another thing I would note is that there
actually is a bill, um, in Congress that I
believe has been introduced by Elizabeth Warren
and some others, uh, called like the tax simplification
act or something like that, um, that would,
that would push the government in this direction.
Um, so, so there is legislation out there.
Um, and the last thing is that, uh, you know,
I, I think you're right that it would be sort
of heavy lift for, um, first of all for Congress
to appropriate money to the IRS to sort of
create its own system.
But there is another option which is the government
could just sort of contract with one of the
companies to create a system and actually
the Pentagon already does this.
Um, if you're in the military, there's a whole
special military tax filing service that's
just a contract, um, that, uh, is presumably
much cheaper.
Um, when you're talking about how much money
people are ultimately spending than than individual
consumers go into like turbo tax.com.
That's super interesting.
It's like taking Medicare and expanding it
to medicare for all.
It's taking the system that's already in place
for members of the military and saying, hey,
we could conceivably expand this to include
everybody.
Um, what else does this act, the taxpayer
first act do outside of what we've been talking
about so far that maybe is less publicized
but important?
Yeah.
So there's a whole bundle of sort of
technical and boring changes to the administration
of the IRS.
Uh, one of the other kind of headline provisions
of it is I, and I think this is one of the
reasons why it got a lot of democratic support
also is that it, it restricts, uh, uh, private
debt collectors from going after, um, lower
income people who owe back taxes essentially.
Um, which apparently is a practice that that
currently happens, which I didn't know before
I started writing about this.
Um, and I believe it also gives some money
to, uh, to another, um, tax prep program,
a volunteer tax prep for lower income people,
which is called Vita.
Um, so there's a couple of things like that,
but it's generally, you know, this bill was
sort of noncontroversial, um, except for this
free file provision, which, uh, after we started
writing about it and writing about the company's
practices and sort of tricks to get people
away from this truly free version.
Um, that provision actually was stripped from
the bill a week or two ago.
So it's, it's no longer in there.
So, let, let's go back to what you said about
debt collectors and people who owe back taxes.
I want to understand exactly what they're
doing.
The idea is that the debt collector would
target low income people who owe back taxes
for what exactly?
Do they fraudulent leak claim that they will
help them with their back taxes or are they
taking advantage of people who might have
other outstanding debts on the basis that
knowing they owe back taxes, they might be
more manipulatable in some way?
Um, my understanding of it is that actually,
uh, the IRS these days use actually uses private
debt collectors to go after people who, you
know, have not paid their taxes in some previous
year.
Um, so, so they, oh, so they owed back taxes
and I believe this was something that, this
is actually a recent development that use
of private debt collectors in the last several
years.
So with this new, with this bill does, is
it says, uh, below a certain income cap.
Um, we don't want these private debt collectors
going after people.
Uh, it's something along those lines, although
I think that the details get some retired.
Yeah.
I mean it's amazing that so debt collectors
and the debt collection world, much like the
bail bonds industry is just rife with abuse,
manipulation and all sorts of shady tactics.
And even at the base level, the idea that
the IRS at all would be using some of these
agencies is a pretty major concern in red
flag to me, although I understand that focusing
on low income probably makes sense because
they're the most vulnerable in the immediate.
Yeah.
I
think this is also part of a larger trend
that actually by my colleagues here at propublic
I've been writing about, which is that the
IRS, you know, obviously no one, no one's
really excited about the IRS, probably don't
want to, you probably don't want to ever personally
interact with the IRS, but, um, it's actually
been gutted in recent years.
Uh, the budget's been cut.
They've, they've had a huge loss in the number
of people that work there.
Um, so as a result, uh, things like the audit
rate for, for the wealthy have, has plummeted.
Um, you know, corporate tax collections have
gone down.
So this is, I, I, my sense is that the, that
the, the pride, the use of private debt collectors
is, is one small part of this larger story
of the IRS just being gutted.
And so they, they can't do functions anymore.
They used to do,
to understand is that that is seen as a feature,
not a bug by those who claim to be about small
government and taking power away from the
government when it comes to taxation and tax
collection.
It's not, that's not your, when I hear you
say that, that sounds like a problem, but
there's a huge political contingent in this
country that says, oh, that's good.
We want the IRS to be hampered and what it's
able to do.
Uh, yeah, that's, that's right.
Um, and I think they would argue that, uh,
you know, um, the agencies too large and it's,
it's too strong.
We don't, we don't want a strong tax collection
agents, uh, agency.
And this goes back to, um, you know, uh, to
at least the nineties when you may remember,
there was a, um, there were congressional
hearings in the mid nineties, I believe, about
a out of the IRS and sort of gone out of control.
And that, that's kind of the, the, the modern
roots of this, this whole movement.
Yup.
It's been around for awhile and it will sometimes
resurface, including under the Obama administration
during the so called political targeting of,
um, uh, on the basis of the political orientation
of nonprofits for audits, which we, uh, of
course learned was not what it was made out
to be.
Uh, Justin Elliott has been a reporter with
Propublica since 2012, but he has been covering
the taxpayer first act recently.
Justin, great to talk to you.
I appreciate your time.
Thanks a lot.